welcome to our career webinar what in
the world
your path to becoming an expert in
robotic
process automation and process
improvement
we're here with laura hendricks senior
vp of
and director of enterprise rpa and
process improvement and quality
at first horizon bank and i'll introduce
laura in a moment but first
just to orient you to the controls on
webex
we will have a q a session toward the
end of the webinar so please enter your
questions for laura
in the q a box hit send and
you can use the chat function remember
to set it to host and presenter or all
panelists
so that we see your questions
or comments um and again if you ask
questions in the chat box we will get to
those towards the end as well
we're going to be doing several polls
during
the presentation and i'm going to start
with
this basic poll
so how much experience do you have
and how are you feeling today we asked
this one
since the pandemic started just to make
sure that
folks are handling work from home and
the other
factors
you know it can be a stressful time
give you another 15 seconds
and interesting poll result
but we find that
most people a little more than half have
more than five years experience but
there's
quite a few who are currently studying
in college and it's nice to see that
most of you are feeling well today uh
for the few who are not we hope that
by the end of the presentation you'll be
feeling better
you're having great information from
laura so
let's go ahead and
close the poll window
introduce laura she as i mentioned is
the senior vice president
and director of enterprise robotics
automation robotic process automation
rpa and process improvement and quality
at first horizon bank
so she has an engineering background
started in civil engineering
and has worked as the global quality
leader
for federal express and now is
at first horizon bank she specializes
in facing and overcoming challenges in
business
that help other people's visions become
reality and
she develops creative solutions by
working collaboratively with the
various stakeholders at the bank to
create new ways of doing business and
that
kind of gets us into the title of the
presentation
what in the world can you tell tell us a
little bit more about that
of course of course
doing i first spoke um we were talking
about the typical day
in rpa and also touched on process of
improvement and i mentioned to him that
there
is no typical day in rpa
basically every day we start with uh
knowing that
the unexpected may come our way
and the four most used words i have in
my vocabulary in the morning
at the moment is what in the world and
he decided to um
he decided to name that this topic for
this webinar
so basically would you like for me to
give a little overview on on robotic
process automation
rta right now let's say
it's really the nature of rpa
robotic process automation because the
the very value
in robotic process automation is that we
work with
user interfaces which by that i mean
screens uh and we also have the
underlying systems the underlying
software's etc
so there's a just a numerous a number
of possibilities for for failures in
there
and glitches uh since the pandemic we've
also been
challenged with with wi-fi latency
and uh so there's just a lot of of areas
that can fail and do at times
fail and then we have no way of
predicting those things that we have
ways of predicting we do but there's
still a lot of moving parts and so
that's
that's why we have have to expect the
unexpected all the time
a particular challenge that came with
covet in the pandemic
last march when we went remote
i was working in back office operations
at the bank and many of our employees
were not set up with laptops at that
time and so those employees transitioned
to laptops the laptops were newer than
what
what we had so they were faster at the
same time
they moved to their homes with their own
slower wi-fi connections and so we had
we had a disconnect
and and we had to um we had to work with
that and we did so
so we've accommodated that very
interesting and very challenging work
yeah and and as you said
varied in the terms of you never know
exactly what the next challenge is going
to be i i think i mentioned when we
spoke
um i had heard an executive and i
haven't been able to track down exactly
who said it
but it was very soon after the beginning
of work from home
and she said you know if they had told
us
that we had to convert everyone to work
from home
we would have said great give us six
months
and 10 million dollars and we'll do it
and when it
happened and they said everybody go home
within three days everybody was working
from hot
with no budget so um i
being able to solve those problems with
that that kind of agility is really
a remarkable area to work in um
so i had a question how did
rpa and business process improvement
dovetail together
that they dovetailed together for first
of all
when we are asked to automate something
we look at the process you know from
from the beginning of the process to the
end of the process
many of these processes have not been
designed
as they are from start to finish they
basically started out at
a then that got added on to b
then c came in d e and so the process
is is not a really good process and so
when we're looking at those processes we
a lot of times we have to improve those
processes
before we even automate and the the way
i have to explain it to the process
owners is
if we automate a broken process we're
going to create a real fast mess
is what we're going to do and so we have
to go back to the drawing
board and look at that process and
optimize that process before we
automate and so that's where where we
really dovetail
in it's a very interesting what we have
at the bank
and and i love it because we
um we have i'm the director over our
quality process improvement program and
also the rpa uh prior to
this in other other not banks but other
enterprises
what we've had is that the the process
improvement side
uh you know here and the rpa
here and there wasn't a joint joining
together
but but we have developed the programs
here where they're they're dovetailed in
and so we really uh we have a synergy
going there that's
that's great yeah and i had spoken with
a scientist from salesforce who
studies decision quality and
he mentioned that in that particular
area where you have your data scientists
on analysts working on artificial
intelligence and
things that can help in decision making
and then you have the business side
which says these are the challenges that
we need to solve and this is what we
want to find out um he pointed out that
it's not just a one-way street where the
business says
here solve this problem and the
data scientists say oh yeah here's the
solution
um that often it's the data scientists
coming back with
this is what we think is possible this
is something that we think we could get
out of the data
and would this be useful to you and so
that kind of
circular flow gets to better solutions
and
better decision support systems and i
imagine it's the same
for you where knowing
all three aspects of it which is the
business
owner's needs the process improvement
view
and what's possible to do with process
automation and rpa
uh gives you that kind of what they call
a
virtuous cycle where everybody's adding
to each other's
capabilities that that fair
that that's very fair and i love that
analogy with the circle because that's
where our quality program process
improvement program comes in
with with that circular continuous
process improvement and
what we do when it's a very large
process improvement is we
we switch it over to the to the quality
program side first
and we engage all the stakeholders
and basically what it is is not a tennis
game of
this person throwing this over the ball
and then over the court then that one
hitting it and coming back
basically what it is is brainstorming
together
so that that we can arrive at the best
solution
and so uh my team acts in those cases as
facilitators and as facilitators we're
not pushing our own agenda
uh we don't we're not necessarily
pushing rpa we just want the best
process
sometimes that eliminates rpa totally
out of the picture
and that's fine and so like i said we're
not we're not evangelists for rpa in
that role we we're just trying to get to
the best solution for the bank
yeah kind of reminds me of the of the
riddle about
the truck that gets stuck under the
highway overpass the railroad overpass
and nobody can figure out what to do
they're thinking
about even deconstructing the overpass
to get the truck out
and a little boy comes up and says mr i
know what to do um
and 10 minutes later the truck is free
and
and it turns out what the little boy
said was why didn't you just let some
air out of the tires
[Laughter]
like you said sometimes it's not looking
for the
complex solution it's just recognizing
when
there's a simple simple solution that
you can arrive at
um but when you're looking for the
complex solutions i mean
one of the questions i had was what is
it like for
your team members to work in in this
area and what are
some of the kinds of projects that they
they get called on to to work on
we get called now from all departments
across the
enterprise so we work with hr we work
with loan operations we're currently
standing up some citizen developers in
our fraud department
we work within our it department we have
citizen developers
in the id management department and so
what what they are faced with is
a multitude of different processes and
some
sometimes it can be a process that's in
one department
and sometimes this process can can
overstep the boundaries and engage
several different departments and so
uh that that's what they do uh typically
when we have these that that really are
overstepping
uh multiple departments especially if
they need process improvement
then we do take them to our quality
program site and form that
team and that can that can be 15 to 20
uh members on that team and we we
identify all the stakeholders
and uh they they become involved with
that
when um so when that happens
stuart my my rpa team
then is not involved on on this side
with us while we're doing this process
improvement until we determine it's
actually automated that that we what
we're going to automate
and so then then i pull in my team
members that that work on process
improvements so if they're
the ones that are working on process
improvement
then get involved in facilitating these
meetings
uh and uh and and running that project
you kind of have to trust the process
uh it's counter-intuitive people that
have been involved with six sigma or
lean
if they they understand uh
we we're having to train and teach
uh our enterprise at the bank uh on
these
on this process of of brainstorming and
really getting to know the process
before we move to solution
everybody you know no matter where we
are and human nature says we want the
solution
and so we we have to go back to study it
so it really
depends upon which side of of of the
fence you're on on my team whether
you're on the quality process
improvement side
or you're on the automation side frankly
most uh
the ones that are on the quality side
right now are also in rpa
what are the kinds of both
hard technical skills and soft skills
that that people need to be successful
in those two have
you know two parts of the role either on
the process improvement side
or on the rpa side or you know together
so for us on the process improvements
side the technical skills are not as
important
as the soft skills that side
really requires a lot of soft skills
there's a lot of change
management that goes on um people
very very resistant to change management
this is this is global by the way
this is across all industries and all
enterprises but people just add
you're fine with it as long as you're
the one changing that
making other people change but try
someone else coming into
your world or my world and telling me
that my process needs to be improved and
changing
and even i'm in like well i'll do it
i'll do it myself okay i'll i'll change
but i'll do it myself
and so that's where the soft skills come
in because
you can get this happens very very
rarely
but you can get on teams what is called
storming
um you come from an engineering
background
as well stuart so you know the the
stages of team development you can
and and that storming can get can get
quite heated
and so you just kind of step off the
stage and and let everybody go back down
so you have to have those soft skills so
that that you not only respond what
happens but you prevent that happening
uh it's not always preventable
but but so that you prevent that
happening so listening a lot
uh instead of of speaking and a lot of
what we do as facilitators
is that we we pull the information from
the subject matter experts
what uh on that side of the house what's
really interesting is that
uh until people become familiar with
what we do
they don't understand why we're
facilitating it because we don't have a
clue about their department or their
process
and so but they come to learn that it's
not we're not the subject matter experts
on their department or their processes
however we
are able to follow the process to engage
everyone
and and try to work toward the best
solution
so that that's what's needed on that
side of the house
most is the soft skills and um
we'll move to the rpa side there are
basically two
two departments on my rpa side
one is the business analyst and what
they do is they work directly with
the business process owners and they
learn about the process
and then they take that information and
they put it into
a document that's called a process uh
process
definition document and that document is
then handed off to the developers
to develop that those team members
need strong soft skills as well
and they need a strong you know right
not in
writing skills but need to be able to
put put words on paper and
be very organized in that not as many
technical skills
needed there and then you move over from
there you move over to the developers
and that's where you have a higher need
for technical skills
but not like a system developer you
don't need
java you know code and
and all that and that's that's
beautifully beauty of
robotic process automation because it's
more of a plug-and-play it's a
more user-friendly and so it's quicker
to pick up however
the the developers still the way they
think the way they come across the
developers
uh and develop these automations that
technical experience and that training
and thinking that way
uh to go through it if then else
statement by those
folks that don't have that kind of a
background
uh what what we do a lot is you you'll
have
if if this and then you take this road
or you take that road and so you you
become trained in your mind to work that
way and so on that side
from a technical standpoint that's what
that is we have had a
very rare occasions when we've uh when
we've had to
to go back to to some code uh but
that's a very rare and far far between
but it's mainly mainly systems level
thinking at that at that
stage where you're you need to
understand like you said the
the logic of the workflow you need to
understand
what paths and branches
you need to construct but uh you don't
necessarily have to reduce it down to
the level of the code
you've got the modules that will do each
function for you
that's correct and and there's several
different
rpa software programs and so
just because you are experienced in one
doesn't mean you can walk in day one
and and do the other but that the
learning
curve is is a lot faster on that than
picking up and being real fluid in java
or
something else like that
where does the what part of your your
operation your which team does the lean
six sigma thinking
i'll fall into that's the that's the
quality program the process improvement
side
also we try we we train and get our
our business analysts to be able to
recognize when they're first going into
the processes and reviewing them
that the processes are are kind of
broken processes or inefficient
processes
and uh and then they they ask us
you know what should be done and then
then we go in
and look at it they become just by
experience
and and working with us and seeing what
we do they become much more
knowledgeable about what needs to go
back to the drawing board first
um so on the
process improvement side some of the
skills lean six sigma as we just
mentioned
but also things like um
program management and project
management type skills
and the change management that's
associated with those
by the way have you ever seen the movie
um
wayne's world the old uh
comedy film wayne's world world no
sorry uh it was based on based on the
skit
from saturday night live and
there's a scene in it where one of the
main characters
is at a high-tech company and watching a
demonstration of a robot
a little robot sitting on the table
doing something and
suddenly the guy picks up a hammer and
starts bashing the thing into little
pieces
and then a guy looks at him like what
have you just done
and he says we fear change
that is true that's that's
kind of one of the one of the great
skills i think that uh
your folks need to have is
to face the universal fear of change
like you said
it's great if i if it's my idea to make
somebody else change but they probably
don't think it's a great idea for me to
make them change so
that's this correct steward and and you
have in training like lean
six sigma i you know i i've had a lot of
training in lean six sigma
i'm i'm i'm a nerd and i'm kind of a
certification addict really
but uh having that kind of training and
also project management training
trains you how to how to go about that
and how to adapt
and to know when to back off and to know
when to come forward and kind of
to manage those instances
so um if somebody in our audience
and i'm presuming that's one of the
reasons why people have
joined us today um if people in our
audience are looking
at entering into
this type of field either on the rpa
side
or on the process improvement side what
streams kind skill areas should they
focus on
uh preparing themselves what are the
what are the aside from
we talked in general about the kinds of
soft and hard skills but
what kinds of certifications for example
might they be looking at getting
so on the process improvement side and
i'll just give it from my background and
what i
did uh but on the process improvement
side it would be the
the lean training the six sigma training
uh what whatever you can can do on that
side and get that training
and also on that side just just as an
encouragement i did not start out
on a process improvement team and
but although it fascinated me i did not
do that
and so what i had control over was the
process of my own computer
right right at my own cubicle right at
my own desk
uh and i started this even when i was in
civil engineering because that
standardization
and being able to improve my
productivity and everything that comes
out of all that
fascinated me and so i had no
influence on anyone else in my company
but i didn't have influence over right
what was in within three feet of me
right and so what i did was i took those
concepts and the things that i was
learning
and i implemented them in my very own
processes
that's really an interesting thing to do
and that's what i encourage people to do
and uh as an outcome of that
my productivity became noticed
and the efficiency and speed that the
executives
could see see my work and and i could be
responsive
improved and so i used whatever i could
macros in excel i didn't have robotic
process automation
etc and so that that's what i used to do
that and so that's the skills you need
to
do uh is improve on that side is to
improve your
knowledge of lean and six sigma
standardization
processes etc um you you touched on
project management
and that is critical uh if whether
you're in process
improvement or you're on the the um
rpa side so that that benefits you
from both those and and incidentally
the lean six sigma and the project
management is across
industries and across whatever you're
doing even if you're
not concentrating on this if if you have
a job
and you're asked to to produce to a
certain goal or a certain deadline you
better be managing it like a pro
like a pro a project uh so project
management comes in
and so then on the uh on the rpa
side uh well there's a lot out there
you can google there's uh simply learn
there's there's a lot of different
offerings that you have
that are available to you and if you if
you don't know what you want to do
um there also most of the software
companies offer
free online training to get get your
foot in the water and see if that's
really something you want to
want to pursue um just a word of caution
though
don't be uh don't be turned away from it
if you
if you do that because you'll be you'll
be self-teaching and
and sometimes it's not as intuitive as
as possible because of uh you know the
the people that are testing it and
they're producing it
come from most of the time more
technological world and so
don't get discouraged but if it
interests you that you know that's a
good way
to look at it and see if it interests
you more
right um and
yeah we found that um offering
um certain parts of our
training for free lets people like you
said
get a feel for it and determine where
the areas that they might want to move
forward and
take more intensive training but yeah it
um
what would you recommend laura to to
people who
want to stand out to employers
you talked about your own personal
experience and how
you developed
the productivity tools that you wanted
to to work on
things personally that made you more
effective
and how that stood out to your
management
so when you when we have people who are
either
trying to do exactly what you did which
is to stand out to their current
management to move up
or want to stand out to
prospective employers what what
things would you recommend them to do to
do to follow on that path
so first of all stupid don't wait for
somebody
else to tell you what what you need to
do
to stand out what what i did and what i
encourage everyone to do
um if you're wanting to stand out at
your current employer
even if you're not wanting to stand out
at your current employer
uh but but you want to stand out in
general if you are employed right now
and i understand some of you may not be
but if you are employed right now you
need to stand out at your current
employer
and for several reasons is that that
employers look to see what your past
history has been
and i know in my roles
with process improvement and with rpa
what i'm looking at as an employer
is for not necessarily the exact
uh experience in either of these areas
but but a curiosity a willingness to
learn
and being proactive in doing that now
what i did it to develop myself and to
stand out was i
proactively looked for ways that i could
improve what i was doing
and as an offset to that that was
naturally noticed from up above and
i was able to produce more they they
were getting what they
liked better in a better format quicker
etc
and so that's what i did and then so
that that is how i stood out
another thing i did and something i
encourage people to do
is a lot of times people
have the mentality that they're not
going to go the extra mile if they're
not
paid to go the extra mile
and so you're really doing yourself a
disservice there
go the extra mile for yourself no matter
whether it's
more money in your pocket at that time
or not
i really think that one of the reasons i
am where i am today is because
i i went that extra mile and and i and i
proactively looked for those
opportunities and didn't have it tied to
a
dollar amount of i'm not going to do
that unless i'm paid
a certain amount and so i proactively
said i think we can improve this here
and and this is what i
can do to do it and i didn't wait for
them to pay me more to do it once they
said
go ahead and go for it um i did it
um another and along that line also i
also
um stuart alluded to me
managing the quality program at
athletics it was at one of the smaller
operating companies at fedex and i
volunteered
to do that because it was a hiring
freeze
and my managing director needed somebody
to do
that i volunteered to do that as a
second job and
ended up doing that as a second job uh
which you know was
not again not paid but not paid
like that but it paid me back in spades
because of my experience i earned but i
ended up doing that
for a year invaluable just invaluable
no money at that time difference but
just invaluable
in the long run what i encourage people
to do
stuart that are not employed right now
and they're trying to get back
in to employment is to
volunteer and if if you volunteer at a
soup kitchen
even if you're cooking soup volunteer at
the soup kitchen
and cook the soup while you're there you
may see
processes that can be improved people
may not want you to again we're talking
about change resistance
but but try to see if there are things
that you can work
on there to help them with their
processes
besides you want to go into rpa or
you're already working on
rpa i see if there's anything there a
project that you can work on
to help them in these non-profits
there's
tremendous needs and see if you can
volunteer to produce automations for
them
most of the software companies now will
give you a community edition
of the softwares for for these instances
and you can work with them
and that's how you gain the experience
that's how you gain the experience when
you don't have the experience
yeah we've had the advice from
people talking about development careers
careers in software development um and
they've
said something similar in the sense of a
universal recommendation is to get
involved
in open source uh software projects
and demonstrate that you're giving to
the community in the form of
doing the work improving the code adding
to the repository and that type of thing
and yeah certainly it applies
far more broadly than just open source
software
like you said any type of volunteer work
that you do gives you um things you can
point to
that say you know i'm proactively
doing something to help and to keep
myself engaged and
what would you look for
personally when you're looking at um
applicant looking for you know if you're
what what do you want to see on on the
resume are
are there particular things that people
should highlight and
what are the things that maybe people
think are important that aren't
so important to you as an employer
well first of all the things that that i
look for
i really look for a curiosity for
learning
you know in a past history of constantly
learning because we have to constantly
and continuously learn
i have to constantly and continuously
learn i also look for someone
who does not want to be
instructed all the time and does not
have to be
told what how to do something basically
when we have these what in the world
moments there's not any written
procedures
and so they have to be that not just
willing to jump in but really enjoy
jump jumping in and figuring things out
and so uh that's what what i look for
i don't i don't so i don't look so much
for um i don't look for for coding
experience and that
that type of experience uh if we're
on the uh process improvement side
and the ba side i look for those soft
skills
and again don't don't care so much about
the technical skills
other industries if you're in process
improvement and
quality they're they're you know like
manufacturing they may want
uh higher expertise and statistical
analysis etc that's not necessary
in banking in my area and so i don't
look for that
okay um
do you put a emphasis on
educational background those kinds of
qualifications
are you looking more at the work
experience
and and showing that people have been
eager to take on projects and
and been eager to learn new things
i look at either or
and so so that there's a trade-off
because you can get
highly educated through experience and
depending upon
what what um life has provided you
a lot of some people have not had the
benefit of being
able to spend a lot of focused time
on on getting particular degrees etc
but but if those same people have show
that they've
been proactive and they have the
experience then
that that weighs out there
um i think you've
really talked about it with in terms of
talking about perpetual curiosity
and continuous learning but um
if somebody is working
on your team or in a similar function in
another company
um what would your advice laura
be to them to keep their career moving
forward
the same type that i would give those
that are on this webinar really
learn continuously never
ever ever stop stop learning um
you know technology is continuously
moving ahead of us it's
always getting ahead of us if you just
stand still for any period of time
you're getting behind so you're not
staying
in you know in in the same platform if
you're not
totally trying to learn i encourage my
team
we have tuition reimbursement at the
bank
we had that also at fedex um
i i regret to say that i didn't always
take advantage of that
uh prior to to this experience but now i
you know if you have tuition or
certification reimbursement
where you're working take advantage of
that
if you're not currently working look for
look for areas where you can get
certified for free
particularly right now with covet and so
many people being displaced there's a
there's a lot of companies that are that
are offering free training take
advantage of the simply learn free uh to
see
what you want that may take you off on a
completely totally different path
and so to take advantage of it but i
encourage
my team don't don't lose that tuition
certification money
each year don't do that um also take
advantage of the free training
and uh i'm big on i'm big on youtube
you know if i don't understand i i
shared with you stuart when
when i was going to the harvard business
analytics program
and i would fall back on uh when it got
to the technical area i'm but mainly
from the business area and so when it
came to i.t
topics i'd say well that's not my area
of expertise
and one of my colleagues at harvard one
time challenged me
and and asked me and said laura do you
know of any businesses
that aren't highly reliant on technology
and i had to say no that i didn't
and so he said well it needs to become
your area of expertise
uh fortunately i was able to be honest
and open enough to him to
tell him that it was overwhelming to me
because there were so many terms and
things that i didn't understand and so
he had come from the i.t side of banking
and gone to the business side and he
said
that he had that same uh on the reverse
he had that same feeling of being
overwhelmed on the reverse
and he recommended that i take one term
at a time
and watch youtubes until i understood it
and then
go on to the next term and so that's
what i would encourage everybody to do
right now whether you're employed
whether you're not employed
you know just be curious and and use
whatever you mean you can to educate
yourself
yeah i mean that's an interesting point
lord that
we encounter things that we have never
heard of
before in our work somebody mentions a
term
or a new area or something
the other day somebody mentioned nft and
nft is a non-photographer
the the reason i knew what it was was
because i have
friends who are artists who use this
technology
to protect their digital artwork um it's
a way to to use blockchain technology
to make a particular
digital file unique and
therefore make it like a signed copy of
a physical
artwork but
you don't need to have friends who are
in the business
to to hear a term like that and say
what does that mean because we all have
google and we all have you know the the
articles being written about our area or
other areas of business
and technology and if you hear something
like that you can start taking that path
find out what it is and like you said
then you can
look into the youtube tutorials and find
out the basics about it
and you may end up learning something
that will take you in a different
direction
even in your your career so um
that curiosity and that that willingness
to to follow those
trails wherever they lead um
is it's a wonderful thing and it's
easier to do than it's ever been before
um i think we're at a point where we
should go on to ask
questions that have come in from the
audience
so we've had a lot of people
who are very curious to hear from you
and so i'm going to
check out a few of these um
first off kind of a technical question
is rpa a replacement for test automation
i'm not sure what they're making by test
automation
yeah now what i'm thinking of is that
the the questioner is asking about
the automation of software testing and
how you'd use the weather rpa would be
helpful in that and
you know from my perspective and i don't
know whether yours
is different um the test automation
tools are
are essentially a kind of rpa
specifically for that purpose so i'm not
sure that it's a
it's really considered an overlap
and we haven't gotten that area in it
with i.t with with rpa stuart
um i do recall i think i believe i've
seen some use cases
uh for that uh that have been presented
but we haven't gotten into that area
so for for that the person asking that
question what i would again we're
talking about google i mean i'm not paid
by google
but but if you um if you're interested
to know if rpa is useful in a particular
area
what what i do when i'm going into a
different department at the bank
is i google rpa use cases and then i add
that area
and uh you will come up with different
information
yep and it turns out that the same
question are asked about
these cases for rpa um so
one of the things you might advise then
is for them to
just use that as a search term in google
and say
rpa use case and add the
the area that they're curious about
correct and also if they want to add the
industry
they'll have better uh results back up
if it's
general uh so you're not in the you're
not
in the finance industry or you're not in
the health industry
uh you'll come back with more use cases
but but
as simplistic as it sounds that is also
what i do
when i'm going into a different
department if if somebody in another
department within the bank
asked me how they might be able to
utilize rpa
i'm able to find a lot of information
like that white papers etc
in general what are the advantages of
rpa
um how is it
probably a general question we could
have started the
webinar with but how has it changed
from the kind of business process
automation or
improvement rather that i did when i
started my career
untold years ago
it's much faster to stand up
much much faster to stand up if you
envision
rather than having line by line code
that was previously done
and having all of the technology uh
developers that that are
very highly skilled tied up with doing
that line to line code
for us to take uh you take this module
plug it in here
and put the parameters and then you take
this module basically and plug it in
there
and plug in the parameters and so it's
much much quicker
it takes a lot less
of the the technology department the i.t
department
to to do this and so that being said you
know there's a lot of things
rpa cannot do that and the highly
skilled developers
have to do but for that portion that we
can we take that load off them
plus we're able to get back to the to
the end users
very quickly the turnaround time can can
be a lot faster but
by that our average turnaround time for
developing is about two and a half
months but as
and but we're getting better with that
all the time
when you're looking at it projects you
can as you know
stuart you can be looking at possibly
years to eat to even get in line
uh and that's pretty pretty standard
across the enterprises
but and so you know that's where we're
rpa the sweet side of rpa
we've also uh as our program matures we
also with our change management
and highly regulated environment even so
we've been able to stand up automations
and get a turnaround time and have them
in production in four days
which is unusual and not only is it
unusual i don't want anybody
if any executives see this to think that
they can expect that
of their employees of ordered their rpa
team because it took
it took everybody from the sea being on
call
24 7 to be able to accomplish that kind
of turnaround so unless they're willing
to
be woken up that that's not gonna happen
um we have a
attendee who says i'm finishing a
certificate
um in process management
would rpa be an extension or
to the knowledge of process and project
management
or does it take you in a different field
in other words if you're if you're
studying uh
pmo and um and you're pmp certified
you're you're studying lean six sigma um
would you recommend adding
uh focus and rpa to to your tool kit
for a person like that absolutely that's
what i did
uh my background is not in rpa right and
so i
prior to to getting the mentality of
that not being my area of expertise it
fascinated me
i knew what it could do but but me
adding that onto my lean six sigma
expertise and background
was a pivotal point in my life and so
i i highly recommend it
um what advice would you give to people
who are maybe from a non-technical
background
who want to enter into this type of
field um what path in
in would you suggest and and
what path forward
i would suggest starting out as a
business an rpa business analyst
and uh start starting that role at an
entry level
and then and then move into
you can go different directions with
that uh
once you become knowledgeable as a
business analyst
you will you will probably pretty
naturally
decide whether you want to to manage
process improvement and lean six sigma
or if you want to go into the uh other
side if you would like to
become a developer but but business
analysts too
or just uh that's a the real good feel
it's a good entry feel if you decide you
want to stay
in that field stay in that field but uh
it's not
as technical as the developer side and
not quite
it's not as challenging on the soft
skill side as doing the process
improvement so that just that business
rpa business analyst
um we have a questioner who's says she
has a
bachelor's degree in mathematics and a
master's in computer science
uh with experience and quality and
quality analysis of products and
what would you advise is
is this a good fit is this person a good
fit
for the process improvement
and and rpa world
yes i do and i think basically
rpa is going to go across
every every industry
every department every feature and
if you if you start reading on what
what's projected for rpa
it's just an exponential growth
and so i i for me from my standpoint
what i'm seeing and what i'm reading
that that uh for for really if you're
if you're prone to to be interested in
that path it's a smart
smart route to go no matter what now now
stuart does
does her background center you like it's
a more of a manufacturing type
uh product product i think yeah it's it
that's the kind of feeling i get from
from her
question okay yes
yeah so so that's that's really uh
that's what what i'm getting to and that
being said so for you
if you you're always more valuable in
the same type area where you have it
experienced but but if you're wanting to
to move on in
but but take a look uh at some of the
ways that
you could use this and do some research
on how you could use
rpa in what you've experienced it's a
really kind of a
new way of thinking about the world it
opens up
how if you look back on what you've done
in that product
area and think about what could have
been automated or if you're still
in that area still employed in that area
what could be automated
it will open up to your mind to start
thinking in those
areas and you'll be able to to find your
way with that
but it for me like i said the
potential is just enormous
i have a question from someone who asks
if you believe that business
analysis certification is critical to
to success in this field
i don't know that the certification
is critical to the success in it but i
will tell you this
i have um one of my so most successful
uh business analyst is has just been
promoted to
offshore manager and he he went the
route of getting the business analysis
certification to to break into the rpa
field
uh whether it was his innate um you know
way of work ethic or whatever i can't
attribute that to
but but i know that certainly uh what
i've seen
from from that is is very impressive
it's very impressive and and by the way
if with the business
analyst certification i think too the
skills that you
learn in that are also transferable if
you decide not to do rpa
because what you'll learn in that
business analyst certification
is to be able to take what you're seeing
from
from the the business process owners and
communicating it on paper
and so whether you're an rpa or you go
into any other area
even if you go into sales if you get
completely away that type of training
still
will help you be able to better uh
assimilate what you're hearing and then
regurgitate it back
yep i i can
attest to that in terms of sales
if you're doing any kind of complex
system selling
it's just vital to be able to understand
the customer's
problem from that level in order to be
able to
match what you're offering as a solution
so
um we have one more question uh
i think is fascinating which is you know
what are the
what are the possible problems you might
encounter um
in a process improvement project
and how would you overcome them
and then i think that's a interesting
question for you laura you might
draw in your experience of you know some
of your more challenging
projects and say you know this is the
roadblock we ran
into and this is this is how we got past
it
uh so yes that's that's interesting and
you do receive this
because there are robots it's not
pollyanna
and uh and so that's what part of the
training does
one of the things that that you run into
uh
a lot of times especially if you are if
you're not coming from a fresh start
if you're actually addressing an issue
that has occurred
the first thing that's going to happen
is this blame game
you know and so people are going to say
it's their fault it's their fault
and um so in your training you're trying
how to
do not hopefully you are i i know i
i received the the bulk of my training
at fedex which is
you know that was fabulous
but um but in the in the training that
we received is
is don't engage in that blame game and
not to let the team
engage in that blame game one of the
first global
um quality teams that i led and they
called them quality
uh they call them quality action team
squats
at fedex but one of the first ones i led
um it was
was a global uh quality team
and uh and i immediately got that
uh and it was that the
the people uh i won't say what part of
the world were blaming
the people in the other part of the
world they were asking me who was the
last one that touched it who did this
another
so so i you know but with my training
and the excellent training i had
received there i knew to say i'm not
going to tell you
i mean i was telling people that we're
way way higher up in the ladder than i
was but i'm not going to tell you that
because we're not focusing on the people
we're focusing on the process
and so that comes into another
challenges a lot of times people will
want to change the people
and if you change the people and you get
another person they come in and you
still got that same problem and so what
what we had to do is is we refocus back
on changing the process and get the
focus off the people
and so that's that's one issue you come
into
another issue that that you come into
frequently across
industries and and no matter what the
process is
a lot of times people want to own the
whole thing
and they they want to delegate
how it's going to be done and throw it
over the fence
and uh to to the other stakeholder
and so we we have to gather navigate
through
that challenge and that issue of that
propensity to want to control it
and to be able and to enable that
ability to
work together for the best possible
solution
a lot of times that comes back to that
win-lose mentality and that's kind of
hard to get around with certain
personalities
but but you want to get to that win-win
uh there has to be
there has to be a give-and-take you know
in order to get to the best solution you
can't have
all one side and or all one another it
has to be a
give-and-take and a willingness to
listen so um
that's the main ones yeah and
that touches also on the on the
ability to diplomatically deal with the
person who
is the boss and
who either takes charge
when they shouldn't in terms of telling
other people what their jobs are
and how you know rather than letting
them contribute to the solution
or the situation where everybody you ask
somebody a question and the first thing
they do is turn and look at the boss
to say you know what should i do what
should i say so
uh that's another aspect of the
group dynamics management that's that's
so important in this area
um so i'm going to move on to
the final poll for today
and uh give me just a moment
and what we're going to ask is what
topics our audience might be most
interested in learning
and given your advice
um when would right now be the best time
to do it
are you asking me a question stuart are
you giving them
i've got a poll for the audience i think
okay okay
but you know we've talked about
project management skills lean six sigma
we've talked about
uh rpa itself we talked in you know
a lot of the things that are around
um in the different related fields but
also
you know as you said
people need to be continuously learning
so you know
what does that apply for you know
somebody who wants to
to learn one of these area is when
should they start
and we'll show the poll result here
so a lot of interest in rpa
and six sigma as well as some of the
other
areas of data science and cloud
computing and
it's good to see that the most popular
answer is
start right away which is a really good
posse because you don't
get anywhere until you take that first
step
so with that i'm going to um
say thank you to laura i know that you
have a slide that you want to share
and i'm going to go ahead and stop
sharing on my side and let you do that
so
i'm still greyed out
there it goes
can you see my slide not yet but it
should be coming up
you have uh the permission now
yep here it comes so there
there's my linkedin feel free to reach
out to me on linkedin
and also uh we will be posting two
different
entry-level uh jobs hopefully
over the next week and one will be for
an rpa business analyst and one will be
for
an rpa developer and so please take a
screenshot
and they will be posted on our website
listed there
so would love to hear from you
if you give me just a moment i will also
type this into the chat box
first horizon dot com
first verizon
national corporation
okay and you should see your chat box if
you're an attendee
you'll see the uh the link
that laura has on the slide there
um she's going to be posting job
openings as she said in the coming week
so keep that in mind if this is
something of interest and you've got
the basic background already yeah
and i will go ahead and
take back the sharing
so again thank you laura i want to thank
everybody
else for being here today i do want to
remind you and i think i've dropped this
into the chat box as well
at some point our skill up program from
simply learn is the free program
that allows you to access a lot of the
video content that we have for our
courses
over 300 skills um a lot of different
technologies including some of the ones
that laura has
emphasized and
you can find that at the link in the
chat box or
at simplylearn.com skillup dash free
dash online dash courses um
and our next webinar will be next
in two weeks actually almost two weeks
wednesday the march
24th uh there will be a webinar
with a group vp from oracle customer
experience marketing
trishti sofat who will be talking about
product development focus automation
intelligence and simplicity
somewhat related topic in terms of using
automated processes to
generate consumer experiences
so please please do join us for that
and want to thank you again all of you
including laura
for being here today we invite you to
keep track of us on our
social media facebook twitter linkedin
and we look forward to seeing you at
future
webinars
thank you stuart it was pleasure
the same here lord great conversation
with you thank you so much
you're welcome